bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal de la rédaction de tv fil 78
nouvelle semaine qui débute est dans
l'actualité de ce lundi 3 novembre
coignières bois d'arcy magny les hameaux
en quelques jours trois braquages
d'hypermarchés dans ce secteur dimanche
matin les employés de l'intermarché de
magny les hameaux ont même été séquestré
c'est dans ce contexte que le plan anti
vma vol à main armée a été lancée de
manière anticipée dans la grande
couronne parisienne nous verrons le
dispositif en place dans les yvelines à
devenir propriétaire un aboutissement
pour bon nombre de personnes encore
faut-il bien maîtrisé son sujet
avantages et inconvénients de la
copropriété avec antoine devaux chargé
de mission au service habitat de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il est
l'invité de ce journal la ministre de la
culture était dans les yvelines ce matin
dans les locaux de renault à flins dans
le cadre de l'opération l'entreprise à
l'oeuvre elle a présenté une peinture
réalisée en 1960 1950 dans les cantines
de lusine une toile de fernand léger
baptisé les constructeurs on ne sait pas
si au cours de la conversation avec les
ouvriers la question de la chute en
france de 3 9% des ventes des voitures
neuves a dévoilé quelques heures plus
tôt a été abordé et puis autre formation
politique la réunion publique ce soir
dans les yvelines à versailles était 20h
de jean christophe fromantin dans le
cadre de la campagne pour la présidence
de l'ue dit il échangera avec le public
à l'hôtel de ville
le député maire de neuilly qui apporte
son soutien à hervé morin face à yves
jégo élections pour les militants
jusqu'au 14 octobre à l es résultats et
qui vont être annoncées quelques jours
plus tard deux malfaiteurs ont donc
braqués à l'intermarché de magny les
hameaux dimanche matin peu après 6
heures les quatre employés
elles sont prêts qu'ils étaient présents
ont été menacés puis séquestré et les
voleurs ne sont repartis qu'avec 600
euros et n'ont pas encore été
interpellés une cellule psychologique a
été mise en place pour les salariés
le magasin était est ouvert ce lundi
matin on écoute bertrand ou lyon le
maire de la commune
agir face à cette situation elle est
interrogée par yolaine torres on assiste
aujourd'hui de manière générale à des
faits qui les agresseurs qui qui ont de
plus en plus loin dans les faits
d'agression pour rien magny les hameaux
il ya des preuves des déploiements
supplémentaire de forces de l'ordre ces
derniers temps pour pour justement
contre contrecarrer ce et ses méfaits
on voit que malheureusement ça ne suffit
pas toujours et il faut qu'on puisse
continuer d'accentuer partout ses
recherches ses tracks de malfaiteurs et
puis un autre braquage aurait pu se
dérouler ce week-end dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche à coignières un homme
de 31 ans a été interpellé alors qu'il a
tenté de forcer le rideau de fer d'un
magasin de plomberie il a été placé en
garde à vue au commissariat d'elancourt
tout ceci intervient alors que le
nouveau plan de lutte contre le vol à
main armée est rentré en application
dans la grande couronne parisienne une
semaine avant le reste de la france en
quoi consiste ce plan les explications
d'anthony rech
ces policiers en tenue parcours à pied
les allées de ce nouveau centre
commercial dans le cadre du plan anti
vma vol à main armée ce dispositif qui a
succédé au plan anti hold up en 2013
prévoit un renforcement des missions de
surveillance des forces de l'ordre dans
les zones commerciales
c'est du bon conseil après notre annonce
y avait des sociétés privées qui nous
aide aussi beaucoup s'en soucier des
marques rôle de bras cassés mais bon
c'est ça fait le cnrj tous vont être
impliqués là-dedans l'un des acteurs
autour de nous donc pour nous c'est bien
avec ce dispositif les commerçants
peuvent également dialoguer avec un
référent sûreté
un policier de terrain qui a pour
mission de permettre aux commerçants
d'améliorer les protections autour de
leur établissement les commerçants
souvent sont évidemment un petit peu
dans la routine chacun dans sa propre
routine pour sa sécurité ne modifie pas
les heures à laquelle ils transfèrent
l'argent à la banque
il ne s'interroge pas trop sur les
allées venues du personnel par des
portes sécurisées ou pas par d'éventuels
le système de badge sur leur système
d'alarmé à des choses assez simples pour
nous mais qui ne sont pas leur métier
sur la circonscription de plaisir six
personnes sont mobilisées 7 jours sur 7
le plan anti vol à main armée prévoit
également des opérations de sécurisation
menée avec les crs et il sera appliqué
jusqu'au 15 janvier prochain
depuis septembre 2013 les vols à main
armée constatés par la police nationale
ont augmenté de 40% dans les yvelines
avant de passer à l'invité de cette
édition petite rectification concernant
les résultats du vote pour la présidence
de l'ue des il s'agit bien évidemment à
des résultats qui seront proclamés en
novembre le 13 et non pas en octobre
depuis est 2000 les charges de
copropriété ont augmenté de 60 2% c'est
le constat de l'association des
responsables de copropriété à l'arc
antoine bourbon soir qu'elle soit vous
êtes chargé de mission au service
habitat de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines ces chiffres ont été
dévoilés et le 6 novembre ont proposé
jeudi une réunion pour le public une
réunion gratuite et plus précisément
c'est un copro dating comment ça va
s'organiser sont des futurs
copropriétaires des gens qui sont déjà
propriétaires
alors tout d'abord un après là il faut
savoir sur
le parc de logement de saint quentinois
50% sont des propriétés ça représente
quand même énormément d'habitants
effectivement je dirais les arcanes des
collectifs les arcanes des collectivités
et des pardons des copropriétés est
assez complexe et donc il est nécessaire
d'apporter une information au clair et
donc c'est tout l'enjeu c'est à dire que
la coletilla communauté de
l'agglomération depuis maintenant une
année propose ces types d'animations des
copeaux dating en fait c'est un outil
proposé par l'adil la dilce --l'agence
des patins départementale d'information
pour le logement se sont une association
conséquent composé de juristes qui
propose de l'information neutre et
gratuite
et donc il s'agit il ya déjà eu
plusieurs réunions de ce type à montigny
voisins hemani et là la prochaine
évidemment c'est le 6 novembre à
guyancourt
c'est comme pro dating sont essayé
d'être composée à la carte pour adapter
en fonction de chaque collectivité de
ses spécificités
chaque copropriété mais qu il souhaitait
aussi pourquoi pas mais on parle bien
des copropriétés ce soit on va évoquer
justement peut-être qu'ils sont en
détail les demandes qui vous sont faites
lors des différentes réunions et
j'imagine qu'avec les chiffres qui ont
été dévoilées encore concernant les
charges et l'augmentation des charges de
ces dernières années ça fera partie des
différentes questions qui seront les qui
seront posées sur la réunion du 6
novembre mais en bas auparavant écouté
ce micro trottoir
c'est notre question du jour quels sont
les avantages quels sont les
inconvénients rencontrés par les
copropriétaires vos réponses
j'ai bien parce que on n'a plus le loyer
à payer mais il ya toujours les cherche
qui courent il ya pas besoin d'autre
chose
cherchez pas je sais pas tout bénef les
avantages c'est que l'on peut peut-être
donné notre idée aux réunions de
copropriété
mais attention attention charge les
avantages c'est quoi on arrive à faire
des travaux en commun en fin de contrat
en commun adopté propriétaire après
l'inconvénient
c'est que l'on choisit pas forcément le
moment où faire ses travaux donc il peut
y avoir des problèmes budgétaires non je
dirais qu'il ya pas davantage en
copropriété les charges sont tellement
élevé il vaut mieux être propriétaire
mais sow d'un papillon que d'un
appartement l'écran ça serait à refaire
je rachèterai pas un appartement une
charge qui inquiète beaucoup les gens on
l'a entendu 6 novembre dès 18h30 hôtel
de ville de guyancourt copro dating
organisé notamment par la communauté
d'agglomération n'en parle donc avec
antoine bon pour la casse qui a séduit
forcément de devenir propriétaire mais
il faut prendre en compte également
qu'il y a pas seulement uniquement des
désavantages est ce que les gens qui
viennent à ces différentes réunions qui
ont déjà été organisées par le passé
rencontre des vraies difficultés parce
qu'il n'avait pas mesuré l'ampleur des
responsabilités lorsqu'on est
propriétaire
alors pour paraphraser simone de
beauvoir on ne naît pas propriétaire on
le devient et donc il faut être acteur
de ceux de sa propriété d'être
copropriétaire c'est vraiment un
tracteur il faut prendre en compte un
certain nombre d'éléments effectivement
lorsqu'on était locataire et compass
copropriétaires eh bien on a des
éventuels mandé nouvelle charge la taxe
foncière et du coup ça demande une
certaine organisation et donc il faut
s'investir en sa copropriété pour bien
suivre
justement les évolutions de charges pour
pour justement être par exemple la
copropriété c'est un syndicat de
copropriété donc c'est l'ensemble des
propriétaires mais ensuite il ya le
syndic le syndic
il administre la copropriété il gère
aussi notamment la comptabilité se
syndiquent qui peut être soit
professionnel soit composé justement de
propres de copropriétaires et donc
bénévoles et puis ensuite il ya le
le conseil syndical qui lui va
surveiller contrôler ce que fait le
syndic est donc aujourd'hui il faut
savoir qu'elle co propriétaire il faut
s'investir dans sa copropriété pour la
suivre au mieux alors concernant les
charges aujourd'hui dans le coffre
dating vous avez une 1ère partie par
l'adil qui évoque les différents régimes
juridiques les droits et devoirs d'un
copropriétaire
puis en seconde partie on a orienté sur
les questions énergétiques il faut
savoir que la lèque l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat informe conseil
accompagne les copropriétés sur les
questions énergétiques parce que ça
c'est intéressant on imagine que faire
des travaux dans sa maison c'est plutôt
simple parce qu'on est le seul à décider
en copropriété c'est plus complexe si on
veut faire des travaux d'économie
d'énergie
effectivement il ya les parties
privatives et les parties communes alors
justement il faut savoir qu'au 1er
janvier 2017 tout copropriété de plus de
10 ans et un certain nombre de l'eau
devra faire une sorte d'audit
énergétique et donc l'idée dès à présent
ses 2,2 d'accompagner les copropriétés a
préparé ce cahier des charges et cet
auditeur jeunes et énergétiques pour
qu'ils soient le plus pertinent possible
et donc la lèque est présent et présente
justement cet accompagnement est
présente aussi il faut savoir que la
ligue propose différents outils
notamment des prêts de caméras
thermiques aux propriétaires justement
pour pouvoir faire des clichés de lors
de leur logement et ensuite les
interpréter avec l'aide de l'alec et les
conseiller sur les bons les bons travaux
à réaliser
il ya aussi des kits de mesures pour
justement se rendre compte si le débit
d'eau est bon c'est l'électricité
fonctionne et c'est pour faire des
ajustements
et donc aujourd'hui il existe un certain
nombre de structures qui aident et qui
accompagnent les copropriétés
copropriétaires sur ce sujet à la fois
sur la partie juridique avec l'adil ou
sur la partie énergétique avec la lèque
et aussi d'autres partenaires
c'est fait partie des questions qui
arrivent le plus souvent ces questions
énergétiques sur les dernières réunions
ont été organisées de sept sites les
codes différents alors la première
partie du coprs dating je précise c'est
une présentation frontale orale un
exposé et la seconde partie qui est là
intéresse souvent les copropriétaires
c'est un face à face la consultation
individualisé auprès des juristes qui
sont présents je crois que quatre
juristes de l'adil seront présents pour
répondre aux différentes questions et
aussi un stand tenu par la lex sur des
questions de travaux alors les questions
sont très vastes
ça va de la fiscalité à des problèmes de
voisinage aux questions avait eu
tellement de travaux aux questions
est-ce que qu'est-ce que je peux faire
dans ma copropriété ou non quels sont
mes droits et devoirs tout cela revient
tout le temps aujourd'hui la copropriété
évolue en permanence le contexte
législatif évolue aussi en permanence et
donc il est assez difficile de s'y
retrouver dans tirez dans la galaxie
copropriété et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
organise ces événements d'informations
qui sont gratuites avec de la formation
précise organisé pour faciliter la
lecture et la compréhension de sa
copropriété vous parlais tout à l'heure
justement d'une façon de réduire ses
charges parce que c'est le post un des
postes de dépenses qui augmentent le
plus ces dernières années pour les
copropriétaires avec ses possibilités de
faire des travaux de réduction de
consommation d'énergie
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres pistes aussi
peut-être pour faire des économies est
ce que est ce que souvent aussi les
syndics qui administre les
les résidences les copropriétés abusent
un petit peu et du coup les
copropriétaires sont un peu perdus et
ont besoin de conseils pour ça et bien
c'est tout le rôle du conseil syndical
donc c'est des copropriétaires qui
composent ce conseil indique al de
vérifier contrôler effectivement ce sont
souvent des copropriétaires ses
bénévoles et donc et il faut leur
apporter cette cette information et
cette expertise pour qu'ils soient du
coup plus précis lorsqu'il rencontre le
syndic sur abba ici peut-être est-ce que
vous avez bien régulé est ce que c'est
bien bien ajustés etc et les informer
des évolutions législatives ce dont on
peut faire ou pas faire et donc
justement c'est apporter ce soutien a
notamment aux copropriétaires bénévoles
au conseil syndical pour qu'ils aient un
peu plus de poids face aux syndics
il ya de bons il n'y a pas que des
mauvais syndic
il ya des professionnels qui font bien
leur travail les ai donc tout ceci va
dans le bon sens là il ya ces réunions
que vous organisez avec la communauté
d'agglomération notamment la dyle vous
l'avez mentionné si jamais on a besoin
d'information peut aussi se tourner vers
la communauté d'agglomération en dehors
alors sur les questions juridiques le
mieux c'est directement de prendre que
de prendre contact auprès de l'adil je
tiens à préciser qu'il ya trois
permanents sur saint quentin en yvelines
donc à montigny guyancourt et et rap
donc c'est des permanences sur rendez
vous et là toute personne peut venir
poser sa question spécifique
pourquoi parce qu'il faut prendre du
temps faut consulter les règles de
copropriété donc apporté après une
réponse juridique viable après on est
relais nous c'est à dire que nous on
connaît un certain nombre d'acteurs qui
pourrait renseigner
donc après on peut re diffuser
l'information et réorienter la personne
vers tyrrell
l'association qui pourrait répondre à la
question est en tout cas il ya le 6
novembre ce rendez-vous qui est proposé
à guyancourt à l'hôtel de ville de
l'hôtel de ville le copro dating merci
encore antoine est revenu ce soir et on
restait guyancourt les écoliers de jean
lurçat d'elsa triolet ont découvert ce
matin d'un tout nouvel établissement
scolaire la rentrée de ce lundi 3
novembre
elle s'est donc faite dans un bâtiment
hqe le haute qualité environnementale
explications 4 nuls à ton image william
penn une façade tout en bois de grandes
fenêtres dans les classes et un toit
végétalisé pour réguler la chaleur voilà
à quoi ressemble la toute nouvelle école
lurçat triolet à guyancourt
ouverte depuis ce lundi matin
l'établissement scolaire reçoit dix
classes de primaire et six classes de
maternelle il est classé hqe haute
qualité environnementale
c'est d'abord un projet technique avec
des matériaux nobles de qualité 70% des
collettes en bois une gestion également
centraliser des équipements avec la
régulation du chauffage la régulation de
la qualité de l'air de l'humidité est
également un projet managériale c'est à
dire que ça a pu mettre l'ensemble des
services de la ville autour de qualité
environnementale dans une démarche
projet un accent particulier a été porté
sur la lumière par exemple des puits
naturels ont été réalisés le facteur
lumière jour comme on dit d'importance
et notamment la haute qualité
environnementale nous oblige à être
vigilant là dessus
ensuite toutes les lumières non
naturelles sont amenés avec des sources
d'énergie les moins consommatrices
possible des régulations que l'on dit
n'obtient à l'aide de la gtb en gestion
technique du bâtiment ou gestion
technique centralisée
tout ça s'est régulé par des automates
donc on essaye de perdre le moins
possible d'énergie et d'avoir un niveau
de clairement le plus bas possible
objectif une réduction de 30% de la
consommation
coût de cette nouvelle école dont le
chantier avait démarré il ya 14 mois
13 millions d'euros dont 1,5 million
d'euros de subvention versée par le
conseil général et le conseil régional
l'école hq et 15 à 20% plus cher qu'un
établissement classique un surcoût
amortissable en 10 à 15 ans quant à
l'ancienne école elle sera déconstruite
à la place 150 logements mixtes
les travaux vont démarrer début janvier
2015 et avant de retourner à l'école les
enfants les adultes aussi on fêtait
halloween fantômes sorcières
monstres qui ont envahi et notamment
voisins le bretonneux à l'occasion de
l'événement faites moi peur
l'association cew déjà organisé
plusieurs animations pour les petits et
pour les grands donc l'intérêt elodie
moines samedi 17h30 à
voisins-le-bretonneux le parc de
l'espace de covile s'ouvre au public
impatient d'aller à la rencontre des
sorcières et fantômes d'halloween avec
l'aide de la ville et de ses partenaires
l'association soudja à gérer
l'organisation est mise beaucoup sur
cette fête le début de cette
manifestation en tout cas c'était de
créer quelque chose dans la ville de
façon à ouvrir un petit peu
l'association aux gens qui sont là pour
présenter nous ce qu'on fait en fait à
l'aller
la principale activité c'est théâtre et
cinéma et après 1 200 fait de la
scénographie donc installations de ba de
décor donc son lumières visuel voilà
c'est dans le but de l'association c'est
ça la nuit tombe
l'atmosphère d'halloween gagne les
visiteurs ici la compagnie garde-fous
présente deux contes aux enfants
on s'est inspiré des histoires qu'on
raconte quand on va en colonie avec la
lampe torche et c est donc on a adapté
un conte de grimm et une scène de tables
qu'on avait joué dans la compagnie qu'on
a réadapté en récit quand il à chaque
fois ya un narrateur est quelqu'un qui
va incarner les différents personnages
photo rapprochant go c'était quatre
garçons qui elle voulait visiter le
manoir est le vieil homme du village il
a dit qu' il y avait un monstre un
fantôme et et un squelette
ça faisait pas trop peur plus loin un
stand de maquillage des spectacles de
magie ou encore cet étrange endroit
interdit aux moins de 12 ans on aime
bien c'est les enfants tout cas sont
appréciés mais nous aussi on trouve ça
original à plus de temps est de la
partie donc voilà c'est une bonne idée
c'est très bien et plein de sens
différent donc je pense que les enfants
ont bien s'amuser ça se passe bien oui
ça fait peur
on va manger d'être des bonbons et cuir
d'un district
mission accomplie ce week end rendez
vous l'année prochaine pour de nouvelles
aventures du sport à présent jusqu'au 6
novembre est organisée la 13e édition
des journées nationales de l'arbitrage à
cette occasion nous avons rencontré là
christophe masson à maçon arbitres de
football amateur expérimenté qui officie
dans le championnat du dimanche matin
anthony rech
comme presque chaque dimanche christophe
masson chose ses crampons mais depuis 12
ans ce passionné de football suit les
matches le sifflet à la main au centre
du terrain je suis pas 3 mètres près ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la reprise du jeu
la rapidité de la reprise du jeu
cet ancien gardien de but est venu à
l'arbitrage par passion et non pas pour
y gagner sa vie car il perçoit seulement
un défraiement kilométrique
à 50 ans il prend le sifflet jusqu'à
trois fois par semaine pour oublier le
stress du travail
mais au fil des saisons il a vu évoluer
le comportement des joueurs
les joueurs sont de plus en plus tendue
je pense que c'est lié à leur condition
personnelle certainement à travers le
travail je ressens depuis au moins deux
ans des gens
des joueurs plus énervés ou un patient
d'ailleurs moi même je suis aussi
affecté par sa fin sur la période de
crise on sent déjà un petit peu plus
tendue l'oeil toujours rivé sur le
ballon ce chef d'entreprise voit le
football comme un sport en mouvement où
le jeu doit être fluide
larbitre ne doit jamais cassé le rythme
son rôle c'est d'être toujours en
harmonie avec le jeu d'être compris il
faut favoriser la communication pendant
le match avec des échanges bref ça
permet aux joueurs de se situer par
rapport aux lois du jeu et la direction
du match par l'arbitrage donc on
souhaite que les arbitres soient plutôt
animateur de jeu en 2002 alors qu'il
arbitrait un match à plaisir christophe
a assisté un règlement de comptes sur le
terrain après avoir sifflé une faute
depuis il prévient et explique toujours
ces sanctions pour vous ce sera la
dernière
cette faute-là l'obstruction qui
l'empêchent d'aller au but on est
d'accord il excentré soit mais attention
c'est la dernière pour vous ce jour là
christophe des livres quatre cartons
jaunes la rencontre remportée par l
encours un but à zéro se déroule sans
aucun problème garder le ballon non mais
toujours difficile surtout avec nous qui
parlons beaucoup c'est difficile de
garder son sang froid quand on est ravi
je crois là en tout cas aujourd'hui
il a fait son job un match plutôt
sympathique
quelques conflits mais pas plus que
d'habitude
le jeu s'est un peu plus félicien des
habitants mais quand même beaucoup de
contestations c'est ça aussi le foot
amateur
le district de football des yvelines
dispose de trois cent dix arbitres et
pour un point complet sur l'actualité
sportive locale vous avez rendez vous ce
lundi soir avec anthony rech pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 sport c'est la fin
du journal je vous retrouve demain mardi
dès 18h en direct nouvelle édition très
bonne soirée